going to talk about liang zeros on 100
degree costs
thank you and thanks for the opportunity
to give a talk here and
it's nice to be here at the simons
institute
um yeah so i'll be talking about liang
zeros and the complexity of the
ferromagnetic easing model on bounded
degree graphs
this is based on joint work with pielter
bass who is at the university of
amsterdam
andreas gallanis oxford and virus patel
also at
amsterdam and this this work fits into
um
into the the broader line of
understanding this this idea of absence
of zeros for partition functions
leads to efficient approximation
algorithms that we've seen it a couple
of times now
the past week but also of course in the
in the original
workshops and um the question is what
what happens
is this an if and only if and what what
is the relation between the
existence of zeros and maybe the failure
of of efficient algorithms
so some people have already looked into
this
in particular beijakova gallanis
goldberg and stefankovic they looked at
this for the independence polynomial
and the matching polynomial and in for
the matching polynomial in fact
um they show that it's no net for the
matching polynomials the roots are on
the
negative real line and all the way up to
the zero freeness
they show a hardness of approximating
the matching polynomial
so you could say that that existence of
zeros and absence of zeros that really
indicates algorithmic tractability there
for the for the matching
for the independence polynomial it's
more subtle
i will get back to that at the end of of
my talk when i
go to open questions and things
and this brings me to the topic of
this talk and that is the the
ferromagnetic easing model
and um so i will um i will tell you some
things about it
so let's first go to um
so let's see i'm somehow
checking what i'm um
go to uh the definition of the partition
function
we have already seen it a couple of
times during the the last
uh last few days but let me just make
sure that everybody is on board here
so we have two parameters lambda and b
and then we define the partition
function for a graph g
as the sum over assignments of pluses
and minus to the vertices
and then we raise lambda to the number
of plus vertices
and we raise b to the number of edges
whose endpoints
have received different signs
so typically in statistical physics the
lambda would be
some e to the two h over two where h is
some some external field and t
is the temperature and b will be e to
the two j
over t where j is an interaction
parameter but
by changing coordinates we can think of
this just as in terms of lambda and b
which is
maybe slightly more convenient and
so we'll just get a very nice talk about
statistical physics and and how
what kind of problems arise there and
and this model um
is one of these lattice models that was
invented to study ferromagnet
ferromagnetism and somehow very
surprisingly
i find i recently learned last year that
it even finds applications
in in theoretical psychology to model
psychiatric disorders
and so i was very surprised to learn
that so this has very
many applications and
far beyond statistical physics
and let me also mention that that some
typically people
um well i don't have to explain here
that the non-real
parameters are interesting
but from the algorithmic perspective one
may wonder why would you want to compute
uh this this quantity uh for um
for non-real lambda and beta or lambda
and b
well this is related to quantum output
probabilities of quantum circuits
as was shown by uh by ryan mann
and and brenner and um
but also there is other relations to
quantum and i will get to that in a
second as well
somehow very surprising and
um and so this talk i will focus on on
the ferromagnetic case as i was
announcing the title which just means
that b
is in the the unit interval
and this will be the physically relevant
case and in terms of algorithms i will i
will look at that particular case
and yeah so since this talk is uh is
about
existence of efficient algorithms or
maybe non-existence of efficient
algorithms let me tell you quickly what
is
or some things that are known uh for the
for the
easing model um so
a famous uh algorithm is the one by
german sinclair that that shows that
that you have an fp res which just means
that you have an efficient randomized
algorithm
to to approximate a partition function
and this is in the ferromagnetic
situation and
for any any positive lambda
and this is quite spectacular because it
works for all graphs
and my talk will be restricted to two
bounded degree graphs so just let me
mention that
by curly g delta i'll denote
the the the family of graphs of maximum
degree
at most delta um
so this is there we have this randomized
algorithm and then in
a few years ago liu sinclair and
srivastava
came up with an fp task which is a
deterministic algorithm
to efficiently approximate the partition
function
and this works for um for b in the in
from minus one to one and any complex
valued lambda
which is not of norm one and
we will see in a second why uh where
this f betas comes from from the
perspective of
zero freeness implies efficient
algorithms
but let me just mention another result
which is due to myself and han peters
and that is that if
you restrict your b to be in a small
um
very close to one here then there is an
arc on the unit circle where you can
where you have an efficient
algorithm to approximate a partition
function so this this allows
for some lambdas where the norm of
lambda is equal to one
and this and here this delta is really
the delta
uh of the class of graphs we care about
the fp
tasks of of leo sinclair and squiggles
alpha doesn't really
depend on delta in the sense that the
parameters don't depend on delta
except that for the algorithm to be
running in polynomial time you first
have to fix the maximum degree
otherwise the algorithm would be
quasi-polynomial time
all right so um so let me state
so as i said this is this randomized
algorithm so let me state the
corresponding zero freeness results
that go with the algorithms and the
first one is of course as
uh will also talked about is is by
famously by lee and yang and that that
says that
if you fix your b inside this interval
then and you think of this z this
partition function as a univariate
polynomial in in the parameter lambda
then
the the roots of this polynomial the
zeros of this polynomial lie on the unit
circle in a complex plane
and then using the barvinock
interpolation methods
you get immediately that
inside the unit inside the unit disk and
then
also in the complement you get you get
the algorithm of liu sinclair as
rivostava
then there's so let me scroll down a
little bit further in
then there is the other consequence or
the other
zero freeness implication for this other
algorithmic results
and that's a result of hong kong myself
is that if b is in this interval then
then there is some some symmetric arc
on on the on the on the circle
for which there are no zeros for the
partition function hence by the same
method
we'll have an efficient algorithm and
let me finally mention another result
concerning zeros because these two
results
the liang result says well if you find a
zero it must be on the unit circle
this results as well there isn't you
have an arc where there are no zeros
now finally this results yeah
independently proved by t.o hey
he rhoda and myself and home
it says that if you look at the
complementary
interval from this one you you took
if you go to the left you go to the to
the left
then the roots of this
polynomial are going to be dense on the
unit circle if you
[Music]
look at the roots over all graphs of
maximum degree at most delta
so this result that says that we have
this zero
free arc somehow as you uh b
approaches this delta minus two over
delta this arc is going to shrink
all the way down to uh to a single point
somehow saying that this these two are
somehow complementary results in a sense
and okay so now we know a little bit
about
[Music]
absence of zeros implies efficient
algorithms
and and here now we have a result
describing where
are the zeros and of course the question
then is
and what does it tell us about about
hardness
and um before reading out the technical
details
i will just tell you that it is going to
be hard to approximate
the partition function on the entire
unit circle if
if your b is in this this interval 0
comma delta minus 2 over delta
and to state such a and actually to
prove such a hardness result we have to
be a little bit careful because we have
to
um just to say what we're dealing with
so we take some some number lambda which
is not a real number so it's not equal
to minus one and one
and it is on the unit circle so absolute
value is equal to one
but we also require that um the
one second here that um
the real and the imaginary parts
that they are um that they are rational
so somehow that's that's important
because otherwise it's going to be hard
to feed
uh to say anything about computational
complexity and we
need to look at the bit size of the
input of course
um and then so what is hard then for the
problem of computing a number which is
an approximation to the absolute value
of the partition function
and so a two approximation but the
number two is very is kind of irrelevant
it could be any number
and so that problem is a is sharply hard
on graphs of maximum degree
delta and even if you further assume
if you respect to those graphs for which
you already know which is given that the
partition function
is non-zero so that
that that in other words i mean the the
the
if the partition function is zero then
this is not uh this is not really well
defined of course
this this approximation guarantee so we
may assume that
uh the partition function is nonzero and
then you want to
to approximate the absolute value of the
partition function
and that's a hard problem yeah so let me
just
reiterate that this is exactly the
region where
zeros are dense on the unit circle so
you could think of this result as
somehow saying or giving evidence saying
that okay existence of zeros
somehow indicates hardness of of
approximating the partition function
um i want to get back to this to this
connection at a later stage after i
i tell you a little bit about some
ingredients of the proof and i will uh
then we i want to discuss this this
connection a bit further
um let me just further mention that that
this
that these rational numbers
uh or that these numbers on the unit
circle with rational real and imaginary
part
they are dense on the unit circle
because we just have a rational
parameter
parameterization of the circle so that
is really just
it really is hard on the entire circle
just if you in case you were wondering
all right so the next uh
next i'll give you an overview of the
rest of the talk and essentially
i want to give you a few ideas
of of the proof and essentially they're
they're two main steps so one is
one is and i guess this is standard in
in in hardness is that you have to
um reduce your problem to some problem
for which you know it is hard
and what we'll do is is somehow will um
will reduce
the problem of um of approximating the
absolute value of the partition function
to exactly uh count computing the
quantity related to the partition
function
somehow having access to this to this to
this
[Music]
approximate norms of the partition
function we can somehow
compute some other quantity exactly
and that hence the sharpie hardness
because these things are
are hard in general and we'll do this by
implementing fields and by implementing
fields i mean just
changing the the vertex activity for one
of the vertices and and
doing that in some kind of a clever way
um and then the way we implement this
fields
is that we'll utilize chaotic behavior
of certain associated dynamical
and and i will also say something about
that
and then i'll get to to some open
problems and questions that
that are still still there
um okay so are there any questions or
comments
at this point moment
in any case if there's questions or
comments i'm happy to take them just
shout in your microphone and i'll stop
okay so let's then get to um some basic
observations around
uh the partition function that that will
lead us to implementing these
these things these fields so the first
thing is that
what we'll do is we fix some vertex of
uh
of the graph and
and and we'll write the partition
function as a sum of two
two parts where one where is where we
fix the vertex to be plus and the other
one where we fix the vertex to be minus
this is of course trivial but it's it's
good to um
to make sure that we understand uh the
notation
and then there's a basic lemma that if
lambda
has absolute value 1 then
the absolute values of these two parts
are equal
and so the reason of for this is the
following that if
your your your lambda is on the unit
circle then then the complex the
conjugate of lambda is just one over
lambda
so if i look at um at lambda to the
power n which this is just an
another number of norm one and then look
at the complex conjugates
of uh of this guy this also doesn't
change the absolute value
and then i will see that this is in fact
equal to
to this guy showing that these two
absolute values go inside
so what happens if you do that so you
multiply by lambda to the n and then you
have this
lambda to conjugate to the number of
plus
assignments and then well
since it's it's uh
lambda conjugate is equal to the inverse
i can replace this by a minus sign
and i can do then i can take this lambda
to the n i can take that inside
so i get an n minus n plus sigma
and now i can just because this b to the
number of edges receiving different
uh signs is invariant under switching
the signs
so what i'll do is i'll just switch the
signs and this one gets a plus
and and and this is essentially the
number of minus
signs so then i i'll just flip that
again and i'll get
just lambda to the number of plus signs
so this is equal to z
v plus hence that the
these two two guys are equal an absolute
value and this is somehow
a very nice it's like kind of like a
one step further saying that that you
can um
that that the the z of one over lambda
is is essentially equal to zero of
lambda
uh um so that the in in
inside the unit disk is like equivalent
to outside of the unit disk and this is
somehow one step further
all right so the consequence of this is
that
um if we assume that the partition
function is non-zero then this ratio
that z
g plus over z g minus this is going to
be on the unit circle and i will use the
notation
s to the one here for the unit circle in
the complex plane
and and this is convenient
to have because we'll have a lot of
it adds a lot of structure to our
problem
okay so we'll have this this ratio on
the unit circle
and so now what i want to do is i want
to explain this idea of implementing
fields
and so essentially what we want to do is
is we're giving a partition function
which is guaranteed to be non-zero
and instead of saying that i can
approximate the exact partition or i can
compute the exact partition function i
want to show that i can compute this
ratio exactly
and of course we're not really there yet
because computing ratios is not clear
that this is sharply hard but then we do
a couple of other steps and then we say
hey we can compute something which we
know is
sharply hard but let me just the main
step is somehow
to be able to compute this ratio exactly
assuming that we have an algorithm that
computes the absolute value of a
partition function approximately
so the idea is so we write this this
ratio which we know is on the unit
circle so we have this expression this
is e to the i alpha
and um which just means that the
z plus is this e to the i alpha times z
minus
let me just mention that and so what i
now
assume or suppose so
i will get i will make uh good on my
promise later
is i i take my vertex v and so this has
a field of lambda associated to it
and i want to multiply this field this
this
external field by e to the i theta so
that just means that
if i have my my my graph and if you
think of the partition function as
something multivariate so
every vertex has its own activity then
then my vertex v will have activity
lambda times e to the to the i
theta and all the other activities stay
the same
you should think of this as a
multi-variable function in that sense
and then if i compute the associated
partition function i'll denote it by z
hat then this results in in multiplying
the z
plus but it's e to the i theta i just
shift it a little bit
and
so i i multiply the z plus by e to the i
theta
but if i choose a particular choice of
theta
in particular if i choose pi minus alpha
then the z
hat will become zero because the z plus
it has this particular
particular form and um
okay so this if i would somehow be able
to if i could find this theta
then i could uh understand so i um then
i could understand when this is zero and
then this
automatically would also determine alpha
and this would determine for me the
ratio
but of course i cannot find this data
because i don't have any any reason how
should i be able to find it
so what happens i also see that there's
something on the chat by the way let me
check
for a second
now will is asking what about minus one
i will get to that at a second
um somewhere towards the end if that's
okay
um so what happens if i vary my theta
this absolute value of this z hat is
going to increase to some point and then
it's going to start decreasing
so what i want to do is i'll i'll choose
i'll just sample like i don't know
take 20 theta as equally spread on the
circle and then i compute
each of these absolute values
approximately
and then i'll see if they what what
pattern do they follow
and then based on this pattern i can
somehow narrow down
the location of this this the right data
then what i do again i'll split that
interval where i've narrowed it down i
split it up in another
bit and then i start doing this this
trick again it starts increasing and
then starts decreasing
or the other way around and then again
further
narrow down the interval and then i do
some binary search and then i'll locate
a very tiny interval around
the right theta
and then what we do is that we use the
fact that we're dealing with
uh lambdas and b's that are rational or
rational coordinates so to speak so um
this function
this ratio cannot have too many it
cannot behave too wildly and then
somehow if i
if i have narrowed down this data enough
then then this should
pinpoint me the exact ratio that i'm
looking for
all right so i should tell you this
implementation of this field
by some number i should tell you how to
do that because now i'm just
uh i i'm kind of like
did something which may may not be be
allowed because i say i can approximate
this number but this
this is this is not necessarily input of
of the algorithm
of the problem that we that we care
about because this is a graph
which for which all the vertices have
filled lambda but one of the vertices
has another field so that that's like
cheating so we should
um i should tell you how to do that
okay um so what we do is we take a
rooted tree
and then implicit factors partition
function of this tree
with lambda and so um z t
lambda b where the lambda b
are as as as always and this partition
function is non-zero that that's not
very difficult to see
so we can look at at uh at the ratio
where we put
the root vertex to plus divided over the
root vertex to minus
and what we do is we we glue this this
this
tree we glue this to this vertex v
and that's going to have the effect
essentially the effect of implementing
uh this this field parameter
so let me tell you this so if i and i
the resulting graph i'll denote by g
prime and then if i look at the the
partition function of
z g prime so what happens if i set my
vertex v to plus
then i'll just get the zg v comma plus
times the the value for the zt
and if i set it to minus i'll get zgv
minus
times the value of ztv
minus but then if i divide on both sides
with the ztv minus
then here this this guy disappears here
disappears
and here um i'll i'll get this e to the
i theta
because it's this ratio over here
so by by gluing trees along the vertices
on
on the specific vertex i can somehow
change the vertex activity
of this vertex to the ratio of this tree
so i would be in business if if uh by by
using and
and we use a tree of degree uh which has
a root degree one so that that doesn't
blow up the degree
of this particular graph and there's a
little bit of
stuff that i'm sweeping under the carpet
but that's not another essential
um so what what i what i would want to
do is
i said in the previous slide i said i
want to
take these state as like i want to
spread them arbitrary around the circle
and then i want to do this binary search
and i want to keep doing that and keep
doing that
so essentially i should be able to get
any point on the circle if i want to do
this binary search
so what i would have to prove is that
the ratios for these trees
they will get dense on the unit circle
that will be sufficient to make this
approach work
let me check the time okay so that's
essentially
the second part of the approach and
that's looking at um
at these ratios of these trees and so
the main theorem there
and that that essentially says if you
look at the ratios of trees of bounded
maximum degree they lie dense on the
unit circle
and and this is really the the heart of
the paper and that took us a lot of
effort to prove um
in order to say something about the
proof i'll i need the definition i think
i gave the same definition
last year i i spoke i spoke about zeros
of the the
the easing model and so what we need is
the notion of a caylee tree and that
just um
a three which has um
i'll just build it iteratively the first
one is just a single vertex the second
one
has two layers the third one has three
layers and we have down degree
a constant down degree at every step
and then if we look at
the ratios for these cayley trees then
so if i look at the ratio for the cali3
at level d
then i can express that as a function
for the ratio at level
um level k i'm sorry d is not the level
d is the degree
k is the level i can express that as a
function of the ratios at level k minus
one
and this is just a simple trick by by
doing the z plus and the z minus
and noting that that the tree has
the subtree is going down and they are
independent so you get this
this factor d in in the in the exponents
and then we divide everything by by the
same quantity and you get this function
um so let me
give this function a name i'll call this
r plus b
over br plus one and and f
which is going to be the function that
describes this the ratio for the caylee
trees
is going to be lambda times g of r to
the power d
and then um so where am i
this was i here sorry and then
yeah we need some properties of these
functions that that are going to be
useful so
first of all we easily see that this is
a mobius transformation
and it's not very hard to see that it
preserves the unit circle
it also preserves the interior and it
also preserves the exterior
this in particular implies that f which
is just a d
power of g times multiplied by lambda
preserves orientation and that's very
very important and
what we also have for this function that
if my b this value is inside this
interval 0 comma delta minus two over
delta
and i take my degree uh to be delta
minus one so the k
tree will have actually maximum degree
delta in this case
and this map f behaves chaotically so
what does k what does chaotically mean
in this setting
it means that the derivative is lower
bounded by one
for all all elements of the circle
so what can i do in that case so let me
i've drawn the circle here so what
what can i do i can i can take a small
a small interval i can apply f to it
and then since it since the derivative
is lower bounded by one or strictly
lower boundary one it will expand
and also since it preserves orientation
it will
move forward and then and then a move
again and then on map again and then it
starts expanding and expanding
and so let's go like this and then what
you see is
it cannot expand indefinitely i mean it
will have to cover the the unit circle
at some point
so what does that mean if i take this
interval here and
somehow i have built um build ratios
from for trees so let's say that i can
somehow build
ratios i have a tree t here that gives
me a ratio inside this thing
then i if what i do and i i'll
if i glue this tree um
to to this scaly tree
and and then and then here once more and
and
and then i'll go up then essentially
um i'm propagating the ratios of this
tree and propagating that
that uh through this by by applying this
map f d minor
by applying this map d and hence i will
get
ratios inside here which are still
ratios of trees
and so what essentially what i want to
do is so
this essentially tells me okay the only
thing i need to do is to make use of
this chaotic behavior is to somehow
get density in some small interval and
then just use the
the dynamics to to expand and to get
everywhere
and remark on why i mean the condition
on b
the endpoint that's a closed interval
right but then you get a strict
inequality out of it
yeah that's something i should be
surprised by or uh so the point is this
is true for
every uh uh number but one
so this this will the derivative is
exactly
equal to one at at the boundary of this
okay okay
but then since it's um so the derivative
is increasing if you if you move along
the circle
then then as soon as you move away from
one then it will be bigger than one
okay okay but indeed there is a kind of
a subtle point that at the boundary you
have to be careful
okay so um yeah so what i said is that
we have this what we want is to want to
find an interval
where we um where we get density with um
with these these trees and if i
if i get that then i can just do the the
the map fd
and apply that to that and then this
will correspond to a tree construction
and to get um density on an interval
i figured i want to give you uh
some idea of of the techniques that go
into it so i will focus on the case
delta is equal to three
so that's like the the most basic case
and so
i'll have this interval zero comma one
over three
and the assumption is then this implies
that the second map
f2 has already uh is already chaotic so
the derivative is lower bounded by one
so in a sense
to construct these trees i can somehow
only use f1
one that's not entirely true but i'll
get to that in a second maybe
but if i want to then so i have two i
have two maps i have two trees i can
somehow do
do this i can make long paths that
corresponds to iterating f1
or i can do or i can do this
which corresponds to iterating f2
and i can also do something else but
i'll get to that in a second
so if i look at the map f1 because it
corresponds to these paths
then what is known from basic theory of
mobius transformations is that there
exists
some parameter lambda such that
if i want to make this green
if i my parameter is on this arc
then the associated function will have
an attracting or parabolic fixed point
while if the parameter is on this part
in the complementary arc
then the map will be conjugate to an
irrational rotation
and being conjugate to an irrational
rotation just means that
uh you can pre-impose multi
[Music]
just means that that that the the
behavior
of this thing is already it is like an
irrational rotation so that the forward
orbit will become dense
on the on the circle so that's somehow
nice
and in this situation when we have this
attracting a parabolic fixed point the
situation is as follows you have some
fixed point
r r1 and starting at one
you you will converge towards this fixed
point
so if it's attracting you will converge
quickly if it is parabolic
the convergence will be rather slow but
still you will converge from from this
side to this attracting
to this fixed point
all right
so that's something that we'll we'll use
um okay so that that's the information
we have on this map f1 now there's two
cases
if for some magic reason the parameter
lambda that we
that we we have is such that this this
function f1 is conjugate to an
irrational rotation
then i claim that we're done because
what we do is we just start
iterating and then with f1 so we're just
making very long paths
and the ratios of these paths that will
become dense on the unit circle
so that's good news okay so that case is
covered
so the other case is that this f1
is not going to go to this irrational
rotation but it has an attracting or
parabolic fixed point
then we have to do more work
actually there it becomes more fun
and then in case two we have to somehow
distinguish two cases
we first look at this this fixed point
and then we have to distinguish we
distinguish the case is this
uh this fixed point is it uh such that
um is it inside this in so let me
make this interval more clear so here we
have this interval lambda one
and one over lambda one so this is this
interval where this associate
map had an attracting fixed point and if
this r0 is beyond that
that thing then um
that that's either is beyond beyond this
interval or it lies in there so i'm
looking at the case where there's
attracting fixed point or parabolic
fixed point is beyond
so what we do then is we take a path
and we we we start iterating and we
start applying this path until we hit
some parameter
psi which which gets close to this r0
which is beyond
this lambda 1. okay so this is a
parameter x i and what we do
is we we kind of cheat a little bit
we're going to take
we want to implement so we we first we
were dealing with
the function f uh f1 or
f1 and f2 lambda but now we want to
change this lambda to this
psi and the way we do that is
at every vertex of our um of our
path this is the long path we have and
at every vertex we glue a copy of the
path that corresponded
to this psi and so we do this for this
vertex and that has the effect
of implementing
disks i know i have to be careful
because i think i made a mistake here
because probably this has the effect of
implementing lambda times x i
so i have to i had to i didn't prepare
this
super carefully um
so let's just uh sweep that under the
carpet for now
and and and try to uh to get
the the main message is by implementing
this
this path here we change the vertex
activity
and hence we change the map and now this
map has a parameter
such that um has a parameter x i
which is beyond this interval so hence
it
is again conjugate to an irrational
rotation and hence
uh uh working with this this map f1
comma xi
we can can again get density on this
entire unit circle
and what we also see is because these
paths are just passed at the maximum
degree
of the graph doesn't blow up it's still
it's still at most
what it should be so that's somehow um
good news um and then there's one final
case and i'm also looking a little bit
at the time here
um which is probably the most
subtle case so probably i'm going to
skip that
um because already you see that there's
quite a
bit of of technical ingredients and this
is only for the case delta is equal to
three
so let me go to the to the wrap-up of
the
of the proof overview so essentially
what we do is
so we had this case delta is equal to
three and we could somehow play with
these
two maps f1 and f2 and if we in a
general case
we'll have to play with all of these
maps and somehow we want to get
yeah we want to find an interval we want
to find a sub arc where we can
get dense and then we kind of do this by
a very sophisticated induction
procedure um
and in this induction procedure we make
use of some number theory some some
elliptic curves and this is actually for
to get
this gives us the conjugate
to this irrational rotation thing
and and and there's a there's it's kind
of
subtle that because the parameters that
we use are rational the
the resulting map is going to go to an
irrational rotation and that somehow
falls from
elliptic curve argument if somehow our
parameters would have been
maybe algebraic with bounded
degree of the the minimum polynomial
then
maybe for all but finitely many
parameters the map will be conjugated to
an irrational rotation so there's some
subtle number theory underlying this
and then of course um that's some basic
mobius transformation we also need some
other
some more but some deeper complex
dynamics than just this chaotic behavior
of this map
fd and then there's another construction
some kind of like we we do a counter
satellite construction to to guarantee
to
to do some other stuff so it's kind of
like there's a lot of stuff going into
the mix
and it took us a lot of time to to make
it happen and we really wonder
whether there is not a simpler argument
to get density on them
on this unit circle and in fact
what you can prove from basic complex
dynamics is that
you'll have if you just start if you
just look at the map fd
so f delta minus one this will um
if you start iterating it so you start
iterating this this map
and this has a lambda associated to it
and you say just look at the orbit of
this map so see where it goes
then for for a dense set of parameters
lambda
this will be the orbit will be dense on
the circle
but there's no guarantee that this dense
set of parameters will have rational
coordinates
so we kind of know like it's like
just uh looking at the orbit of this
thing might be enough but there's
it's going to be very tricky to prove
that
and um yeah so we had to
to to dive into uh
into some of the more
detailed aspects of these things so
that's
what i wanted to say about ingredients
of the proof
now i want to go back to this question
of zeros versus hardness
and so last year when i spoke about
zeros of the easing model
i also talked about some complex
dynamics and i also said that chaotic
behavior somehow
implied the the existence of zeros
this is somehow um
the same is true for for this hardness
because
an essential ingredient was to to use
this
the fact that this map is expanding this
fd map
so that that we can make these intervals
bigger and bigger and bigger
and and so both underlie
uh the existence of these zeros and so
and and this density of these uh
of these fields and and and the
consequences that we get hardness
and but somehow there's there's a subtle
difference in the in the sense that
that for this for the hardness proof we
we have our land eyes a fixed uh input
and
it has rational coordinates and we
cannot somehow perturb landa a little
bit and then just say oh we'll just work
with some lambda close to it and we'll
just do it with that
because that's of course not then we're
proving hardness for for some other
lambda
and while with zeroes um
we can perturb actually lambda and so we
just look at the found
this family of maps and that sends
lambda to the nth iterate
of uh of the the the lambda map
even starting at lambda and then
and this is uh uh and then then we can
use this and this is somehow
the the the reason that we can do that
makes the zeros prove almost uh a few
lines
well the hardness proof is like i know
20 pages or so of
a very complicated induction which is
maybe somebody comes up with a better
proof and then i'm not saying anything
here but um
so far it is 20 pages
um and and so this um
backs the question i mean so so getting
back to this the the
the theme the starting theme of this
this talk is that
okay so absence of zeros implies
efficient algorithms existence of zeros
seems to indicate hardness but is it
really the existence of the zeros
or is it this underlying phenomenon of
the chaotic behavior of the dynamical
systems
that that indicates the hardness um
i leave it to you too to decide what
what
what you think what you prefer um
so was it yeah so i i have an idea of i
have a feeling what what i think is is
the
is the right answer but i i don't i
don't want to speak it out loud
yet um i would like to
uh go to uh some open questions and
problems
um and maybe before i go there i can
address
will's question who asked so yeah what
is the complexity about
approximating the the partition function
at lambda is equal to -1 which is a real
point on the on the unit circle
yeah so what we showed is that it's
equivalent to computing
approximately computing perfect
matchings
so it is um it's not sharply hard
but it's still yes maybe
unresolved maybe that's the best way to
uh to say it
um yeah so i showed you in the beginning
this the zero freeness result that if
this is this is not right here this
should be
interval 0 comma i
this should be a different interval
there should be an endpoint to this
interval this is comma 1.
so if b is in this interval i showed you
this result that we had is this arc
where you have where you have zero
freeness
and and in the and what we also show in
our paper with home is that on the
complementary arc the roots are dense
and yeah so this leads of course to the
question is what is the hardness of
computing the partition function
on the complementary arc where there are
zeros
and so we tried analyzing that
but somehow we failed so far
and we we suspect that it's hard and we
suspect that the way to to prove it is
using this this dynamical behavior
but in in our proof we make use of the
fact that the derivative
is uh of these fd map is lower bounded
by one
and we kind of lose this property if we
go on this complementary arc so that's
kind of annoying
and finally i want to make a few remarks
about the independence polynomial
um i promised this
in the beginning of the talk so we i
think i've seen this picture in another
talk this week or variant of this
picture
so this is say the prototypical picture
of the
the locations of the zeros of the
independence polynomials of the green
thing is the shearer disk
uh this is i don't know what this is
this is something which
peter cigari and ference bench proved
this purple
thing is although it goes all the way up
to the right bound this is due to
myself and this blue cardioid shape
thing
the interior of this doesn't contain any
zeros for the scaly trees
and what we proved is that that roots
accumulate on the boundary of this this
object
and so what um so we asked the question
so what is the hardness of
approximating the independence
polynomial and then bezakova
and goldberg and gallanis and
stevenkov it's proof that it's indeed
sharply hard outside
the cardioids and so so far this seems
like a good picture so zeros
no zeros of course you're inside here we
don't know but at least on the outside
we do know but then um my student
pilter bows found
actually curves cutting inside
into the cardioids and and with
roots um
how do you say that arbitrarily close to
the boundary of these curves so there
are roots cutting
four bounded degree graphs so they're
not uh cayley trees of course but
they're like some clever combination of
alternating layers like
have level like down degree d down
degree d minus one and then
clever combinations and these these
curves they cut into the
to the thing and um somehow like
destroying the beautiful picture that's
there so
it's much more complicated then
yeah we initially initially hoped
and um so when we started our project we
actually wanted to prove that it's hard
to compute um the the the independence
polynomial uh
in the boundary of the interior of these
curves so like like cutting in inside
here
would we we didn't manage to do so
because um
i don't know because of what maybe we're
not clever enough in any case we didn't
manage to do so and then we ended up
proving this stuff for the for the
easing model but but here really the
connection between zeros dynamics and
hardness and efficient algorithms is
still i would say rather open
and probably it's going to be a very
complicated picture
if if it's going to be resolved at all
yeah so with this i'd like to thank you
all for your attention
and um yeah that's it
thanks a lot really nice talk any any
questions
okay so i have one question so is there
any need to prove a bound on the rate
at which the uh these
uh roots that you get from the cayley
trees become dense because the trees
get bigger right and they're part of the
input so
i mean is your error that you're
shooting for a constant so it doesn't
matter or is it if it depends on n then
you have to control
how fast this becomes dense right yeah
that's a good question
um i think so i think here so because of
the the
we have a given lower bound on the
derivative i think you can you can
easily see how quickly you expand you'll
cover the circle so i think you can
probably it goes pretty quickly like log
n
maybe it goes like log n but do you need
i see but you you actually use that in
the proof i guess because you need the
trees to be not too big right
we don't say anything about the size of
the trees i mean so so what question do
you ask at least for the for the zeros
or for the hardness
uh for the hardness so ah yeah you need
the trees to not be huge right
yeah yeah definitely so the trees are
are going to be constant size
okay essentially um
yeah i think that yeah so given um
so they're going to be where you have
your input
graph and your input lambda and
b so they they will determine the size
of the inputs
and um so all these trees that we
compute somehow
uh are independent of the inputs so
they're really
i mean the size is going to be huge but
they don't they don't depend on the
inputs yeah
they only depend on the error that you
get at the end right
like the density parameter that you that
you uh
okay and no but i mean in your reduction
in the end you you
you showed that if you could compute
this you could compute something
exactly right yeah but i guess you don't
really mean exactly you mean like one
plus epsilon or something
what is exactly is really exactly
because because it's a rational
uh this ratio is uh has rational
coordinates
so you can somehow it's like um you
should think of it as a
as a lattice point in some some very
huge space and if you get arbitrarily
if you get close enough to a lattice
point then it can only be that lattice
point
okay but then but then don't you need to
be able to choose very fine values of
theta
and then you need a very good bound on
how quickly these trees
give you thetas that are dense on the
circle um
so that's a good question uh yeah so you
don't need
very fine bound because the trick is
that that it has this increasing
decrease in property so you get
um um
so let's see
[Music]
yeah so i think if i recall correctly i
think the bounds that we have we need on
the theta are not um
they don't don't depend on the well
i have to be careful here um
saying that they don't depend on that
yeah so i would have to like dive into
the to the technicalities of the crew so
i cannot tell you by heart right now
what the dependence actually is but um
but you can get whatever
you need basically yeah yeah
i guess one more question is so you had
to do a lot of work because you
really you needed this to work uh
for rational lambda uh because of the
input model would it become much easier
if the input was given as a
root of an algebraic like an algebraic
number like this as a root of
some polynomial like could you suppose
you worked in the symbolic model of
computation where you could
represent numbers by other minimal
polynomials
yeah so then so then you wouldn't get an
exact algorithm for computing the
uh this ratio then you would get a very
good approximation
um but i think uh other than that
except maybe there are some subtleties
with um
with some of the um with this
being that this particular mobius
transformation is conjugate to an
irrational
rotation because it also somehow depends
on the input parameters and
rationality gives that they are
conjugate or irrational if they're
algebraic then there's only a finite set
of them
which for which they're not conjugate to
an irrational
uh ah okay but then you have to worry
about what that is and stuff
yeah and then yeah so that's that's a
little bit possibly finite set and then
you would have to
either try to find out proof that it's
not that the finite set is empty or not
and that's
somehow we were able to do that in the
rational case but for lgbt we figured
okay this is gonna
going to give us too much headaches okay
so it doesn't make your life easier it's
the point
it makes your life harder to do
algebraic
yeah and also it doesn't it's not
because that's still
um i mean somehow it would make our
lives
easier if we would say okay well we'll
just uh
we take the lambdas for which the
forward orbit of this this expanding map
uh covers has a dense orbit
and that would make our lives very easy
at least for that part of the proof but
then of course we don't know anything
about these lambda so if
you have algebraic then then this would
make things
yeah there's hardly it's very hard to
say anything there i think
but presumably if you wanted to prove
hardness in some real number model of
computation
then you could try that route you need
to find some other hard problem
in that model whatever that is yeah yeah
so you would
you would maybe it's not clear what if
um because here we really make use the
fact that if you get
close enough to a rational number then
yeah
finite bounded number of bits then you
have to be that you know
yeah you need some approximation
hardness for something yeah there are
very few hard problems in
the real model i see i see basically one
and which is that well solving the
system of polynomial equations
okay yeah so i think that would be
tricky then
to reduce to that i don't see that as a
possibility
so um so
so do you know what happens for the
anti-ferometic eating model but
fields off the circle
so so what the question is for the
anti-ferromagnetic easing model and then
lambda to be off the circle yeah
um no to be honest we
don't we have looked at it and i think
at least
the reduction part um probably goes
through but
somehow um so we looked a little bit at
what happens on the circle and there
you can't improve some some stuff on the
circle
but we thought it's kind of like um
like the circle is very restrictive
because we don't really know where the
the zeros are but there there's some
there's some results on them
so we kind of didn't know where to look
for what london has to play with
essentially and i think a lot of this
work could go through
uh although the the fact that the
associated transformations
no longer preserve orientation make
things more difficult
yeah but then again that
would still be if you're on the circle
and if you're off this circle then then
then it would even be more difficult but
maybe at the same time it could be
easier
um yeah
so yeah don't yeah i don't fully know
but i think definitely part of this will
definitely
could go through
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
space
for the anti-ferromagnetic regime yeah
yeah
yeah yeah and
yeah so yeah i think the reason that we
didn't look at it because we didn't
really know what would be the best um
yeah best place to look or to
well yeah what would be nice to know
what would be nice to know that's hard
or what we
that yeah we don't
but yeah so if you have any one more
yeah please go ahead
so on the under on the real line somehow
so the complexity drops it's also like
the for the hardcore
model for example and for the
anti-feminist model we know this
phase transition and there is np
hardness for approximation on the real
line and
at least for the hardcore model we know
that just as soon as you move up it
becomes number be hard
like the approximation problem also yeah
uh so if so is uh i mean
that's that's a phenomenon but is there
a
another explanation for it or
sort of yeah it's not a very
well found question but no but i think
it's a very good question because i
i actually did start thinking about
especially the hardcore model
and but then you know that the dynamics
beyond the lambda critical then you just
haven't
have a attractive attracting orbits
beyond uh beyond lambda critical and
that's not
that's not chaotic behavior of course
that's that's still
from the complex dynamics perspective
yeah it just goes to infinity
or something like that and uh so so i
mean it will still
still attract uh things and
but somehow yeah so somehow it's still
the fact that it doesn't converge to a
fixed point but that
has this this alternating behavior
somehow people still manage to to get
hardness out of that um
yeah so i don't have yeah so maybe
because it's not
chaotic behavior if you could if you
would get chaotic behavior then then
definitely
i think sharpie hardness seems
reasonable because you can somehow get
anywhere
anywhere anywhere you want and you can
somehow implement anything
in principle and that and yeah that that
is a good indication that you uh work
for heart for sharpie hardness and and
maybe in this this other reduction is
more maybe more refined or
it's more subtle maybe
but yeah somehow i feel like like
sorry i didn't quite get what you were
saying there was a bit of noise on the
line
yeah i somehow feel like that like this
underlying dynamics has some
something to say in all of this but i
don't fully or
and one final comment which is more of
an apology so this
independent said picture there is some
updates to it which i think jan already
announced last year
and we in fact finished the write-up
last year but we have never
someone ever got along updating it we
have been updating it this week
so
yeah that's very good i mean you mean
you mean this picture right
yeah so that there's some stuff yeah let
me let me draw it there's some stuff
um here um
yeah and uh yeah and also like
actually yeah it goes you can even
extend a little bit on like as
far high up as the security area the
bench
yeah and uh yeah i somehow forgot about
it and i knew about it but um
it's our fault because we never we never
uploaded it
so yeah but yeah but now we will in soon
yeah so we suddenly
woke up uh last week
good to know i look forward to reading
it
so i mean this might be a naive question
but is there some re intuitive reason
why this should be hard at lambda equals
one
uh lambda is one
so not this the the using model i mean
the ferromagnetic model at lambda equals
one
it's not hard at equipment oh it's not
hard okay good good it is randomized
but it's not deterministic
it's easy probabilistically
and maybe maybe somehow our result could
say that that
looking for zeros uh is you know already
know you notice the zeros accumulated
one but uh
that arbitrarily close to one it is hard
somehow you would have to to look at it
from a different angle maybe
yeah the mystic algorithm yeah i suspect
that
one is easy somehow because zero is
rather symmetric right you're squeezing
in between
two conflicting heroes
sorry and there's one interesting thing
about the randomized algorithm at lambda
equal to one also is that it does not
actually work at lambda equal to one
what you have to do is to perturb lambda
a little bit to lambda equal to about 1
over n
then run the algorithm there and just
argue that lambda equal to 1 over n
gives you a good in approximation
so y 1 over n i mean 1 over polyn so
depending upon the approximation you
want you have to perturb lambda by that
much and run the algorithm there the
algorithm does not
work at some degree in fact the markov
chain that you use is not connected
um oh yeah and but you can also do
random customers saying you think so
that that's just yeah okay so that's
that's maybe okay that doesn't guess
what i was saying is not
true for that but for the first group
the
gerund sinclair flu uh that markov chain
is not even connected at lambda equal to
one you have to perturb it slightly and
run it there but
the perturbation can be so small that
you can actually get the good
approximation yeah so in a sense
this lambdas one is is a hard point in
that in that regard
yes but as heng was point hang with us
pointing out random cluster does not
have this problem
and the random cluster was to hang and
uh
to convert to be faster
yeah so maybe if you want to do it
deterministically you have to also go
via the random cluster model maybe
or maybe i mean it sounds like the first
uh resolution was that you do one by one
over poly n so maybe this problem
i mean in this correspondence between
hardness and zeros maybe you want to say
are there zeros in a disk of radius one
over poly n
yeah yeah i think that is because the
problem is robust to moving by one or a
polyend or something right
or i mean okay you need to qualify it
more than that because you could just
move away from the circle but
i mean yeah
great well thanks a lot so
i guess tomorrow's the last day and see
everybody
tomorrow yeah thanks bye
thanks